وهينورنا ونشكره على وجوده معنا بعد غياب
الفنان جورج خباز هو مؤلفها مخرج وممثل
ومؤلف اغاني وملحن لبناني وعمل للسنوات
على خشبه المسرح نجحها خلالها في استقطاب
جمهور عريض من مختلف الاعمار والفئات
الاجتماعيه تالقا عبر مسرحه الخاصه الذي
طبع هويته الفنيه من خلال مجموعه كبيره من
الاعمال واعاده تقديم مسرحيات لزياد
الرحباني حصاد جورج خباز شهره واسعه في
التلفزيون عبر سلسله من الاعمال الناجحه
وشارك في عدد من الافلام فازه بعضها
بجوائز عالميه كان اخر افلامه اعز الذي
اثار ضجه كبيره عند عرضه على منصه
معنا في الاستديو الفنان الجميل جورج خباز
نشكره على هذه المقابله مع نفس صباح
العربيه اهلا بك يا جورج والحمد لله على
السلامه معانا على الهواء وعلى كذلك
الدراما الله يخليك اول شيء صباح النور
وانا كثير سعيد انه موجود معك بالبرنامج
احلى وفخور بانه انا موجود في دبي لحتى
نفتتح مسلسل براند والشاب السوداء
[موسيقى]
فرق لتحقيق حلم هذا المخرج
المغور ليحقق اولى اعماله اذا بدك ولكن
بنفس نكتشف مع الوقت ان هي رحله بحث عن
الذات
بهالرحله بيصير في كثير همم ما بدنا نقدر
عناصر المفاجاه بس بيصير في كثير همم
احداث وبيصير فيه كثير همم مشاعر تجاه في
المحطه حد ذاته مش بس اتجاه الاخر فمسلسل
في كل انواع الدراما بيونت وحده يعني في
الدراما في الكوميديا في الميوزكلي
الفانتازيا في همم رومانسي يعني كل انواع
اللي بنشوفها بالدراما موجود بدون نت وحده
بيتنقل بطريقه سيلفي من خلال شخصيه يوسف
هو المخرج الباحث عن البراندو شرق لحتى
نكتشف عوالم هذه الشخصيه وكواليس الاعمال
الفنيه خاصه بالدور احداث وباخر بيانات
اول التسعينات ففي كمان بنحاس الشكل في
بوك حلو كثير وه حقيقي كثير كبيره للمخرج
امين دورا يلي نقل هالمسلسل او ترجموا
برؤيه اخراجيه رائعه طيب
اهلا فيك في صباح العربيه
جورج يجمع بين الطموح وعدم الاستسلام
ومحبته لوالده بنفس الوقت انزعاجه منه في
المسلسل يعني هذه الشخصيه المركبه يا جورج
هل تمثل جورج وسلام الزوج بعيدا عن
التمثيل
لا ابدا انا الحمد لله كنت محظوظ انه انا
رميت ببدل واهلي تركوني اعمل اللي بدي
اياه ولكن شغله الفنان انه يكتب بس همم
جدليات وصراعات بالمجتمع ويحولها لمشهديه
انا بشوف كثير من تلاميذه كوني بعلم
بالجامعه وبعلم الفنون شوف كثير مثل
الميزه حيره ابو اهله بقيتهم لحتى يفوتوا
بهذا المجال
واهلهم كانوا يحطوا لهم مثل ما بيقولوا
عاصي وليد خوفا علي لانه مجال الفن ممكن
يكون صعب واقول له ما يطعم خبز وكل هذه
المقولات فكانوا هذا الشباب والصبايا همم
لدرجه
انه التحدوا
واراء اهلهم التقليديه وفاته بمار مجال
الفن فانا اذا بدك نقلت اصواتهم بشكل او
باخر بس انا صعيد شخصي لا كنت محظوظ جدا
انه
تركوا لي هاي مش حريه كبيره اني اختار
اعمل بالدقيقه حياتي طيب
نجاحها شخصيتك وهويتك التمثيليه المتفرده
والمتميزه تجربه اصحاب مؤثره فعلا
على العالم مش بس على العالم العربي على
العالم كله همم من الباب العريض مثل ما
بيقولوا انا كان عندي كنت محظوظ انه بلعب
شخصيه حلوه
بالفيلم
وصارت كثير كثير شهادات نحو هذه الشخصيه
فتحت لي كثير همم
العمل
شركه الصباح يا اللي جامعاتني بيشاهد همم
مسلسل براندو الشرق اللي هو كان حلم
بالنسبه
عم بفكر فيه من حوالي اربع خمس سنين وانا
عم بخطط لهذا المسلسل
بدي يكون في انتاج لائق فيه فاجيت شركه
الصباح طبعا مع بلاك فور شاهد
الشهير واللي عن جد عم تغني المكتبه
الدراميه في العالم العربي اييه تبنت هذا
المشروع وحمد لله وصلنا للوصولنا لهلا
باول حلقتين المسلسل عامل دوج كثير كبير
له
اا على المسرح او على ال ال التلفزيون او
على السينما من خلال كتابات وشخصيات معينه
بس في شغله كثير مهم انه انت الفن المشهد
هو جدلي يعني واحد عم بيقول ايه واحد عم
بيقول لا اذا اثنان وعم بيقولوا ايه صفوا
محاضره وهون بنفشل اذا تنانين عم بيقولوا
لا صفه مظاهره اما لما بيكون واحد عم
بيقول ايه واحد عم بيقول لا نحن صفاينا
بلعبه الفن المشهدي وهذا اللي بيخلي الناس
تنتمي لانه انت عم تقطفي من جدليات عم
تحاوليها لمشهدريه
مسلسل قصير واليوم برنده الشرق الحلقه فقط
كبير بينكم الاول لحظات التصوير الفيلم
انا وياها لانه انا معجب فيها من زمان
المسرحيه
وكنت ناطر الفرصه انه نشتغل سوا في عمل
حقيقه نحنا تقريبا من نفس المدرسه ياللي
هي ال ال يعني امل عرفه بتلعب كوميديا
بشكل كثير رائع وبتلعب دراما بنفس الوقت
بشكل كثير رائع فماذا لو جمعتيهم الدراما
والكوميديا مع بعض بعتقد انه ما حدا غير
ادى امل عرفه قادر يكون بهادل ففي تناغم
كثير بيناتنا لانه عندنا اذا بدك نفس الهم
الفني والانساني فكنت جدا سعيد انه همم
كانت معنا براند والشرق وعملنا ثنائي رائع
ما بدنا كثير نحرقه عناصر المفاجاه نترك
هذا الشيء الحكم الجمهور اما بالنسبه
للاصيل
انا كثير كنت بتقول انه نحضر مسلسلات من
30 حلقه او من 60 حلقه بيقول حرام هذا
المسلسل مشاعر واحداثه بتحمل عشر حلقات
مضطرين لاسباب الماركتنج انه يمغطوه تحسي
في رغي وفي ضيعه وقت وفي بعض الاحيان ما
معمن بس بعض الاحيان في استخفاف بعقل
المشاهد بس للتعبئه الهواء والوقت فانا
برايي لا انه اذا بنعمل عشر حلقات همم
مضبوطين بايقاع مشدود همم بمشاعر بس لازمه
للعمل وللاحداث الاساسيه الاحداث انا
برايي بنجح اكثر ومنطور صناعه الدراما
اكثر
السؤال الاخير همم جورج اذا بدنا نحكي
عمران الشرق والاعمال الاخيره
خروجها عن المقلوب ولكن في ذات الوقت
رقيها بنفس الوقت هل جورج انه اليوم سهل
الممتنع هو اقرب للمشاهد من اي انتاجات
اخرى
والحقيقه يعني كلمه تكوني عم تعكس الحقيقه
كلمه المشاهد عندما همم لك اكثر كلمه كنت
بتشبه هيك هموم الناس مثل ما قال لنا
وسيرها
وبتشبه هي يومياتها كلمه الناس انتوا لالك
اكثر هو مش قصه سهل
هويه الناس حتى
الجمله تمام
دينا نورتنا مشكورين معنا حصريا صباح
العربيه جورج خباز شكرا جزيلا شكرا لكم